digamos que tengo un alambre de 100
metros y vamos a dibujar este alambre
que tiene 100 metros de longitud que
todo esto es una longitud de 100 metros
ok y voy a hacer algún corte en la en
algún lugar de este alambre por ejemplo
digamos solo vamos a hacer un ejemplo
que aquí fuera el corte y de tal suerte
que lo que voy a hacer con este lado
izquierdo con este lado izquierdo es un
triángulo ok un triángulo y que además
ese triángulo sea equilátero muy bien
mientras que de este lado con lo que
tenga de longitud de este lado voy a
hacer un cuadrado ok entonces este
alambre al cortarlo con la parte
izquierda vamos a hacer un triángulo y
con la parte derecha vamos a hacer un
cuadrado entonces con esta longitud este
digamos y esta longitud es x entonces
queda claro que por ser equilátero es
cada uno de los lados es x sobre 3
verdad con este pedazo de alambre lo
divido en 3 y puedo hacer cada uno de
los
de este triángulo mientras que cada lado
del cuadrado será de 100 menos x sobre 4
verdad porque porque si éste mide x y
todo esto mide 100 entonces pues a éste
le corresponde ser 100 menos equis
verdad al sumar estos dos nos debe dar
100 entonces cada uno de estos lados
mide 100 menos x entre cuatro verdades
este lado azul partirlo en cuatro
pedazos pero bueno la pregunta para ti
para mí es bueno para todos es cuál es
el punto ideal en donde vamos a hacer el
corte para minimizar el área combinada
del triángulo y el cuadrado ok entonces
para eso necesitamos dar una expresión
del área en términos de x que es la
longitud en al cual voy a hacer mi corte
entonces vamos a empezar digamos con
este triángulo equilátero vamos a ver
cómo se expresa el área
más o menos de esta forma y nosotros
pues digamos que lo podemos hacer en
general digamos si éste tiene longitud s
de de cada uno de los lados
sabemos que el área de cualquier
triángulo en particular este pues es la
mitad de la base la base por la altura
verdad esto es básico del cálculo de
áreas de triángulos en este caso cuánto
mide nuestra base pues entonces el área
es si esto consideramos nuestra base es
un medio de s por la altura ok
ésta va a ser nuestra altura nuestra
altura h
ahora lo que necesitamos es determinar
esta h en como función de s y cómo vamos
a hacerlo bueno consideremos este
triángulo izquierdo este triángulo
izquierdo de aquí si nos damos cuenta de
guaqui quizás el dibujo no es muy
apropiado déjenme corregirlo un poco
pero esto por ser altura sabemos que
forma un ángulo de 90 grados verdad y si
forma un ángulo de 90 grados también
sabemos que la base de este triángulo es
ese sobre 2 es la mitad de esta base
correcto entonces qué es lo que podemos
hacer con este triángulo como es
rectángulo pues podemos usar el teorema
de pitágoras que nos dice el teorema de
pitágoras que la suma de los cuadrados
de los catetos es igual al cuadrado de
la hipotenusa este cateto es h cuadrada
más este otro cateto que es ese sobre 2
al cuadrado debe ser exactamente igual a
ese cuadrada que es la hipotenusa esto
no es otra cosa más que h cuadrada más s
cuadrada entre 4 y debe ser igual a ese
cuadrado
nosotros queremos despejar h cuadrado
entonces
escribir h cuadrada es igual a s
cuadrada menos s cuadrada sobre 4 y para
poder hacer bien esta operación podemos
poner aquí que es 4 s cuadrada entre 4
verdad para tener un común denominador
entonces y aquí tenemos cuatro cuartos
menos un cuarto pues son tres cuartos de
s cuadrada
13s cuadrada sobre cuatro entonces
finalmente h cuadrada es 3 s cuadrada
sobre 4 que si sacamos la raíz cuadrada
tendremos que h es raíz de 3 por s sobre
2 muy bien entonces ya tenemos esta
altura esta altura ya la tenemos podemos
sustituirlo y tendremos que el área el
área es igual a un medio de la base que
es s por la altura que es raíz de 3 por
s sobre 2 entonces si realizamos todas
estas operaciones por ejemplo un medio
por un medio es un cuarto aquí tendremos
raíz de 3 s por ese es ese cuadrada ya
habíamos dicho un medio por un medio
un cuarto entonces este valor es el
valor del área de un triángulo con base
ese entonces ya escribimos que nosotros
queremos calcular el área combinada pues
el área combinada no es otra cosa más
que la suma de las áreas verdad la suma
del área del triángulo más
el área del cuadrado muy bien entonces
si sustituimos esto tendremos que el
área del triángulo es esto que obtuvimos
aquí donde la base quien es x entre 3
verdad entonces tengo raíz de 3 sobre 4
por la base que es x sobre 3 al cuadrado
verdad es el papel de ese lo juega x
entre 3 y después tendremos que sumar el
área de este cuadrado que es base por
altura verdad y la base como es igual
que la altura es 100 menos x sobre 4 al
cuadrado 100 - x sobre 4 al cuadrado ok
y esto es el área combinada esto es el
área combinada y lo podemos poner en
términos de x muy bien
esto es lo que necesitamos minimizar
aquí tenemos qué
mini
a mí ni a mí ni me sale esta función es
la que hay que minimizar y eso es lo que
haré en el próximo vídeo